hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on for honor again and
today we have two bits of information
and also two videos releasing today
the first video which is this video is
gonna be a teaser for the new season and
the executions
with the video going out a little bit
later in the day gonna be the full
details on the new season as currently
we don't have the information just yet
which i'll explain in this video
as to why that's the case as i like to
be if you do enjoy subscribe if you're
new
let's get started with today's video
like i said for the agenda today we're
gonna have the new season teaser
and then the executions i'm just gonna
play the new season teaser in full right
now and then we'll discuss it when it's
over
maybe the warmongers were right
maybe we were foolish
to hope for more
maybe we deserve to be
punished
it would be easier to give up
and let them decide our fate
but we won't
[Music]
because it only takes a spark
to start
a rebellion
so yeah not much info in terms of actual
gameplay things we might be expecting
like
you know new battle pass new mechanics
new stuff like that
none of that stuff obviously this is
just more of a teaser trailer with lore
but the lore is actually a little bit
interesting so with year 4 season 1
hope this was all about bringing the
peace together between the factions
as we know with year 4 season 2 tyranny
the mongers arrived and then ruined all
of that
and it seems like in year 4 season 3
resistance the characters are now
banning together to bring the peace back
amongst the world by
killing the warmongers so that's kind of
interesting i never thought that this
would happen but i feel like it's kind
of expected now with the
kind of havoc they've been causing
recently in the past season there's also
going to be three executions death by
catapult death by spears and death by
arrows
i'm questioning if these are the
seasonal executions we get every season
or not so be usually they're hero based
and every character gets a unique
execution of them
but this time it's faction based but
even if that were true
the wulin don't have an execution this
time around which is a bit confusing
regardless we have three new executions
that are 7k each
the catapult is going to be for the
knights only the spears are going to be
for the vikings only and the arrows are
going to be for the samurai only
according to the tweet from the devs
though at a later date the executions
while
currently faction based will be
available for every hero at a later date
even including the wulin now i don't
know if this means the woolen is going
to be getting their own unique execution
meaning we now have
four unique executions to share across
the cast or that just means the woolen
are going to be included with getting
the three executions we just talked
about
either way currently only the knights
can use the catapult the spears are
going to be for the vikings and the
arrows are going to be for the samurai
with like i said at a later date every
character is going to get all of them so
i would most likely just wait
because maybe the spears look really
good for a character that isn't part of
the vikings and maybe the arrows look
really good for someone that isn't part
of the samurai
and that's really about it for today's
video just keep in mind though that
within an hour of this video roughly
going up ubisoft forward should be over
by then
and the devstream should be starting
where ubisoft forward gave us the teaser
for the due season the warriors then is
going to
sequel that and give us the full details
on the new upcoming season that we just
talked about so
keep an eye on that video in the next
couple hours or so with that like if you
do enjoy the subscribe if you're new
and take care i'll see you in a couple
hours goodbye
[Music]
you